you are watching KOAT Christians
hey welcome to another ColdFusion video
to go go here and today the note 4 is in
the house yes that's right you'll be
joining me in taking a look at the
Samsung Galaxy Note 4 ColdFusion style
it's a device that brings a little bit
of sophistication to what was once a
design 'less hold all right so let's get
straight into it the note 4 a slightly
heavier than last year's model but the
build quality has improved tremendously
and it actually feels great in the hand
it doesn't have that typical Samsung
squeamish toy feel anymore think along
the lines of HTC that's kind of what it
feels like now I'm not really a fan of
the new speaker placement and also the
button rearrangement from the s5 but
those are my only gripe so far the
version I have in my hands is the lte-a
Exynos version so what most people
aren't talking about is that this chip
is 64-bit that being said it's running
on 32 bit for this current version of
Android but when the next version of
Android comes we could possibly be
seeing a large advantage over most other
smartphones the new CPU of the octa-core
version has improved tremendously since
last year's model and is slightly better
than the Snapdragon model this time
around
it offers 74% more graphics power than
last year's Exynos model and 54 percent
more CPU power than last year's Exynos
model this version of the note has the
same graphics power as the late 2010 in
Nvidia graphics card okay so you might
be wondering why do we need all this
power flow is for three reasons one the
extensive multitasking abilities to that
2k screen and three for virtual reality
gaming and of course it also doubles as
a bit of a workstation when you plug it
into your computer monitor with a mouse
and keyboard of course
all right so some quick thoughts in the
device the screen looks absolutely great
everyone that's seen it always comments
on how sharp and crisp it is the front
camera is also decent the battery life
is good you get about six hours of
screen on time and will easily get you
through a day of normal use and just
generally all around it seems that the
details that were missed last year were
paid much more attention to this time
around and let's talk a little bit about
the camera in my time in reviewing the
device I've definitely found this to be
the biggest surprise and why is that you
might ask well you can take a look for
yourself
this was all shot on the night force
camera
if you're actually careful the image
stabilization actually works really well
just look at this shot I could actually
see some people shooting some actual
short films of this thing 4k resolution
isn't that terrible after all the only
thing that I'm confused about is how
they got such depth of field in such a
small physical space and that zoom can
get pretty close too yes the Lumia 1020
might be better for the notes camera was
just simply a pleasant surprise the
camera sensor is made by Sony and it's
so good because the sensor is 15 percent
larger than the average sensor used in
all smartphones great job by the Sony
engineers here and Samsung for their
software processing okay so some more on
that radically improved build quality so
I'll just set up this shot with the Sun
reflecting off the phone so you can
really see the phone's curves and all
the subtle details that Samsung has put
in this time the biggest improvement
would be the feel and response of the
buttons the headphone jack and the
metallic trim on the sides which does
come across as a bit sharp so the
situation here is the sum of all these
little changes equals a solid device
that is better than the s5 or anything
that came before it the design is quite
seamless though so it actually can be a
bit slippery so be careful software wise
it's still TouchWiz and I frankly wish
that Samsung would just abandon it but
the good thing is you can completely get
rid of it for example this launcher is
called Vox US and was designed and built
by a friend in Ireland it will be in the
description if you're interested once
you get rid of TouchWiz in the S voice
feature waiting for the home button
press the phone absolutely Flyers it has
great performance so if I could roughly
quantify it personally
I'd say that this phone is the best note
by about 40 percent so the question is
should you pick one up so far I'd say if
you're coming from an iPhone or any
Android phone that's more than a year
old it's at least worth a look and as
for the note 3 users which I know
there's probably a lot of you out there
it's really a story of refinement rather
than reinvention so with that that wraps
up my brief overall look at the Galaxy
Note 4 this was the initial review and
not the for review but that being said
if you do want to see the full
ColdFusion review make sure you
subscribe so you don't miss it and are
updated
the latest so just before I leave I do
have a little something I did manage to
get a bit of spare time and created an
experimental concept music video for a
song that I produced the link for this
video the Vox is launcher and Amazon
links to buy the note 4 will be below
thanks so much for watching guys and I
will see you guys soon for the next
video don't forget to give a thumbs up
if you liked it comment and subscribe
I'll leave you with this cheers guys
[Music]
cold fusion its new thinking